I'm literally moving into college today
and she still might be there cuz despite
reports Olivia Jade has not formally
dropped out of school yet as you know
Olivia and her sister Isabella have had
a tough time caught in the middle of
what's turned out to be the biggest
College Admission scandal ever after
recent reports claimed Lori Lachlan had
withdrawn her daughters from college the
University of Southern California
released a statement Monday writing we
have confirmed that both Olivia Gianelli
and Isabella Jian Ali still are enrolled
the university reiterated they are still
conducting a case-by-case review for
current students and graduates that may
be connected to the scheme alleged by
the government and will make informed
decisions as those reviews are completed
Lori and her husband Massimo were among
the 50 people charged in the college
cheating scam last week a source told et
Bella and Olivia are suffering in their
own ways from the fallout of their
parents decisions since news broke of
the scam Olivia lost to major sponsors
Sephora and Tresemme a source told ET
the 19 year old youtuber feels her
parents quote ruined everything she's
really angry with her parents because
she told them she did not want to go to
college and she was pushed but I do want
the experience of like game days
partying I don't really care about
school as you guys all know our source
says that out of the two girls 20 year
old Bella was more invested in college
and wanted to complete her time at USC
but Olivia is quote so embarrassed
she doesn't even want to go out that's a
lot on a teenager yeah it is I want them
to be happy so I want to be supportive
of everything they want to do but I do
want them to have somewhat of a normal
you know finish out of high school
college experience maybe because I
didn't have that I would really want
that for them court Doc's allege
Olivia's parents paid half a million
dollars to have their kids recruited to
USC even though they never played sports
I just want them to have that experience
and get that education and have a degree
to fall back on USC announced students
involved in the scandal that have holds
placed on their accounts are prevented
from registering for classes and can't
get transcripts while their cases are
under review that would explain why
Olivia and Bella haven't been able to
make any moves or maybe even wanted to
yeah as you can imagine this can
overwhelming for any student thankfully
Olivia and Bella have a tight circle of
friends who are standing by their sides
our source ads they've needed that
support because they are being attacked
at every turn so months before the
scandal Lori seemed supportive of her
girl stepping into showbiz but she told
UT that she gave them a fair warning
about what comes with this industry what
about your kids are they wanting to
follow in your footsteps my older
daughter wants to be an actress I'm a
younger one is quite a successful
YouTube channel based around beauty and
fashion so I think in some way they're
both destined to be in the entertainment
industry how do you nurture that and
support that you know I just have to I I
look I did everything I can and my
powers to say when they were younger
look these are the pitfalls these are
the pitfalls and these are the pitfalls
and then they both decided like you know
we're gonna do it anyway so I have to
support them I would be a hypocrite if I
didn't and you know what you know we're
here once that we know of go for the go
for the gold right you got to do it Lori
and her husband are due back in federal
court on April 3rd after being released
on 1 million dollar bonds do we think
both Olivia and Bella will drop out of
USC on their own terms
time will tell and as this investigation
continues we will keep you up-to-date so
be sure to subscribe to ET until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens and I'm Courtney
teza know bye for now guys
you